Narrator: Vladimir
Putin has told the world
that Russia is gearing up
for a mass vaccination program in October.
Narrator: The key word here is registered,
after less than two months
of human testing on fewer
than a hundred people.
Russian researchers are actually behind
several other groups in the US and China.
In terms of the science,
they've bent the rules around approval.
- My initial reaction was
it was probably much ado about nothing.
We don't know anything about this vaccine,
other than the fact that Vladimir Putin
got on the airwaves and said
this is going to be safe,
this is going to be effective.
And one can only interpret
this as a political stunt.
Narrator: So, what's missing?
The most essential step in proving
a vaccine is safe called Phase 3.
It's the last phase of human trials
and it usually involves
tens of thousands of people.
- So, without that Phase 3 data yet,
I'm very concerned that they will be using
and releasing a vaccine that
could potentially be unsafe,
could potentially be just ineffective.
- Russia passed laws in April
that would allow companies
working on vaccines
to bypass Phase 3 trials.
Other countries have also
changed or accelerated
the process by which vaccines are made.
China OK'd a vaccine for military use
before publishing Phase 3 trial results.
And in the United States, companies funded
by the Operation Warp Speed program
are overlapping multiple
phases of clinical trials.
Still, Putin has confidently claimed
to have tested the Russian
vaccine on his own family.
Narrator: There are
currently more than 100
coronavirus vaccines in
development globally.
Researchers around the world
are in a race against time and each other.
But developing any new
vaccine typically takes years,
sometimes up to a decade.
So far, only a handful of groups
in the US and UK have entered Phase 3.
Their plans for deployment are, as of now,
a bit less ambitious than Russia's.
In the United States,
the Trump administration
partnered with the private sector
to deliver 300 million
doses by January 2021.
And China has already offered
an experimental vaccine
to employees of state-run companies.
The first country that
proves it can produce
a safe and effective vaccine
stands to gain billions of
dollars of foreign investment.
The vaccine will be marketed as Sputnik V,
a nod to the world's
first satellite Sputnik I,
which the Soviet Union launched in 1957,
escalating the 20-year
space race with the US.
As many as 20 countries have
already expressed interest,
perhaps putting Sputnik V
in the lead of a biotech cold war.
- I hope it's not a cold war.
Certainly this pandemic has been
an equal opportunity employer.
This virus affects all nations,
all ethnic backgrounds,
all religious groups.
We should all be brought
together in this effort
because all of us are at risk.
I think what Vladimir Putin
has done is political theater.
Narrator: Russia's
vaccine is being developed
at the Gamaleya Institute in Moscow.
But in July, American, British,
and Canadian intelligence services
accused Russian hackers of
trying to steal vaccine-related
information from researchers abroad,
according to The New York Times.
And there have been widespread reports
that scientists injected
themselves with the prototype
and rushed through other tests
to speed up the development.
- So, when people talk
about this being a race,
I say be careful what you wish for,
because history tells us when you look
at the modern history of
the US vaccine program,
the first vaccines out are usually
replaced within a year or
two by better vaccines.
Narrator: Dr. Peter Hotez
has researched vaccines
for other coronaviruses for decades,
and they are notoriously difficult.
He says that the only way nations
can solve a pandemic is by cooperating.
- I think we have to get
away from this business
you know, of this
nationalism around vaccines,
calling it the American vaccine
or the Chinese vaccine
or the British vaccine.
It doesn't work that way.
Narrator: Historically,
nations have come together.
- This concept of vaccine diplomacy,
how you build vaccines
jointly between nations
at the height of the Cold War
and the two countries put aside
their ideologies to work together.
They did that for polio
and they wound up doing that
for the freeze-dried
smallpox vaccine as well.
- Those studies that were
done in the then-Soviet Union
were instrumental in getting
Sabin's oral polio vaccine
licensed in the United States.
- And many Russians never considered
the coronavirus to be a serious threat.
- So, people didn't take it
seriously in the beginning.
Russian propaganda tried
to present coronavirus
as a part of some great foreign
conspiracy against Russia.
- So, even if the Russian
vaccine doesn't work,
Putin has little to lose
politically from approving it.
- So, he needed to enforce his image
like a savior, a defender,
like someone who can
"make Russia great again."
So, if we are talking about people's life,
yeah, it's huge risk.
But if we're talking about Putin's
political and informational risks,
I don't think they're too high.
- Putin's announcement could be a tactic
to destabilize the vaccine
process in other countries
and potentially undermine trust
in vaccines in Russia and abroad.
Tara Smith studies vaccine hesitancy
at Kent State University in Ohio.
- You have that ripple
effect that, you know,
well, this one is not working
or if this one causes side effects,
well, what about, you know, measles?
What about tetanus?
What about pertussis?
It can drive fear for those as well.
Narrator: If the Russian
vaccine does prove
to be safe and effective,
manufacturing enough doses
to share with the world
would be a tremendous challenge.
- If the intention is to vaccinate
8 million people in the world,
that's going to require something
that's never been done before.
- Dr. Stanley Plotkin is the godfather
of the rubella vaccine,
one of the most common
vaccines given to infants.
He says there's no plan in place
for worldwide collaboration.
- We'd have to suspend antitrust laws
and allow collaboration between companies,
and the companies would have to agree
in some cases to manufacture
somebody else's vaccines.
The only way that will be possible
is if we have some sort of
agreement now between companies,
whether brokered by the
WHO or somebody else.
I don't see that happening yet.
Narrator: The World Health Organization
has said it is discussing
the new COVID-19 vaccine
with Russian health authorities.
- We hope that some of these vaccines
will prove to be safe and efficient
and that you will be able to get doses
that will be distributed in an equal way.
- They have now got 14 vaccines
that they're moving forward with.
The hard part comes, as you
note, with what happens next.
I mean the hardest part
of this is going to
be implementation and
distribution of these vaccines.
- Russian officials confirmed
that Phase 3 trials for their vaccine
moved forward with 2,000
volunteers on August 12.
One day after the announcement
of the vaccine's approval.
Mass production of the vaccine
could begin as soon as September,
a month earlier than results are expected
from Phase 3 trials for Moderna,
the US company furthest
along in the process.
Russia was approaching 1 million
reported cases in mid-August,
putting it forth on the list of countries
with the most confirmed
infections in the world.
More than 15,000 Russians have died.